voici la cabine familiale si on est à 5
dans la cabine
on est à cinq à pouvoir entend ce que
dit l'être cher aux tenues au moins et
on peut être 5 à lui répondre en même
temps
innovation le cadran est remplacé par
des boutons dont chacun quand on lan
clanche émettent un son ainsi chaque
numéro de téléphone devient une petite
chanson plus agréable à fredonner que
les numéros d'autrefois
[Musique]
mieux encore le picture phone il vous
suffit d'appuyer sur un bouton pour être
vu par votre correspondant
alors qu'un grâce à ce système dont la
première fois les compagnies de
téléphone s'intéresse aux sourds muets
pouvant suivre à distance les mouvements
de leurs lèvres ils peuvent enfin se
téléphoner comme les autres
[Musique]